bonjour et merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 week-end tout de suite le
sommaire de ce vendredi 18 décembre
mardi 15 décembre avait lieu
l'inauguration des médailles du roi à la
librairie des princes du château de
versailles un partenariat entre la
maison arthus bertrand et le château de
versailles pour présenter un ensemble de
17 médailles inspiré des collections
d'époque claude chose président de l'uar
16 associations de photographes et en
plateau pour nous dévoiler le nom du
gagnant du concours photo lumière de
fait qu'il reviendra sur les critères du
jury et nous donnera quelques conseils
et comme chaque vendredi vous
retrouverez la sélection de laurent gare
un gérant de la librairie du pavé du
canal de saint quentin en yvelines
il vous proposera de découvrir les
routes du miel d'eric tournerait et
scylla de saint pierre
mais comme je vous le disais donc tout
de suite le sujet sur l'inauguration des
médailles du roi mardi 15 décembre était
donc inaugurer ce nouveau cabinet à
versailles un partenariat entre la
maison arthus bertrand et le château de
versailles pour présenter une collection
de dix sept médailles
inspiré des collections d'époque
l'occasion de créer quelques ressources
pour le château tout en participant au
développement de cette entreprise du
patrimoine du sésame pour entrer dans
les jardins du trianon sous marie
antoinette aux décorations officielles
des jeux olympiques
les médailles ont toujours été des
témoignages de l'histoire frappé
poinçonnet doré et patiné les médailles
harbour différentes fonctions depuis
l'antiquité la médaille avait plusieurs
symboles s'il fit dire d'abord c'était
une manière assurée de pouvoir
transmettre son image à la postérité
parce que c'était de préférence dans un
matériau inaltérable ensuite la médaille
pouvait être un outil de propagande
à partir du moment
mettez en avant vos victoires votre
famille et c'est également donc outil de
propagande complémentaires sachant que
les médailles notamment les médailles en
or servait de cadeaux diplomatiques
louis xiv fervent collectionneur de
médailles pour glorifier son règne avait
même aménagé son cabinet des médailles
au château de versailles en 1684 celui
ci aujourd'hui disparu le château a eu
l'idée de s'associer à la maison arthus
bertrand pour lancer une collection de
17 pièces
hier avait lieu dans la librairie des
princes du château l'inauguration de
cette collection nous on est passionné
de médailles
on avait depuis longtemps lui toute la
littérature autour du cabinet des
médailles du roi louis xiv est un grand
collectionneur et on est attaché à cet
art de la médaille on avait proposé au
château de versailles de reproduire pour
le château des médailles déjà anciennes
ou existantes dans les fonds du château
est en aussi en inventer on essaie de
faire en sorte avec le château on puisse
les lieux mais un peu étrange et puis
avoir quelques ressources
complémentaires et l'idée c'était
justement de reprendre des médailles
puis de commercialiser où j'avais dans
tous les lieux historiques des petites
médailles à vendre pas cher n'est pas
forcément de très bonne qualité et sans
forcément un grand lien historique en un
moyen de créer des ressources pour
entretenir le château de versailles tout
en développant l'économie des
entreprises du patrimoine tels que la
maison arthus-bertrand des maisons qui
sent toutes les commandes de
restauration serait amené à péricliter
et en plateau avec moi claude chose
bonjour je suppose que le jazz vous êtes
président de l'association de
photographes de l'union régionale 16 de
l'ouest ile-de-france alors comme chaque
mois nous allons découvrir ensemble le
nom du gagnant du concours photos que
vous organisez avec tv fil 78 mais avant
rappelez-nous en fait sur quels critères
on est a été fait cette sélection par le
jury alors le jury composé de quatre
personnes donc dont quelques
quelques la rédaction de tv fil 78 ainsi
que deux photographes
je dirais aguerris à un juge et une
bonne quarantaine de photos ce que nous
avons reçu que les veaux téléspectateurs
ont envoyé et le thème était lumière de
fait
alors lorsqu'on a lancé ce concours il
ya à peu près 1 - lumière de fête pour
nous c'était la lumière de fêtes de noël
donc on a vu quand même de très jolies
choses qui nous ont été envoyées sur les
feux d'artifice etc sur les décorations
de noël qui ont été faites mais comme on
ne sait quels critères
mais pour moi le critère c'est vrai tu
es si vous venez de parler de l'humain
quoi donc l'humain le regard mais revêt
émerveillés des enfants devant laisser
si vous voulez toutes ces illuminations
de noël et enfin les ou même des adultes
parce que pourquoi limiter à des enfants
après tout nous sommes des grands
enfants et donc que quelque part s'il
voulait qu'on puisse vraiment se
focaliser sur la lumière que de la fête
qui s'approche de noël malgré les
événements que deux ont eu
malheureusement comme on dit la fête la
vie continue et il faut que cibler on
sache s'adapter à ça donc on a reçu
voilà plusieurs clichés vous en avez
sélectionné si ce que l'on va découvrir
me semble alors je propose qu'on
commence en fait par le cinquième qui et
on va le voir voilà celui ci un mot
peut-être pourquoi mais ce supplément
le jury a décidé que c'était la
cinquième faute aux lumières de fait
c'est une lumière on voit un piano ciblé
c'est une
c'est une photo qui à mon sens un sens
contemporaine mais quand on regarde bien
cette image on voit le clavier d'un
piano si vous voulez avec la lumière qui
se posent sur quelques notes bon
je dirais que c'est quand même une image
qu'il ya un certain intérêt qu elle qui
fait travailler l'imaginaire je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez sephora mais bon
c'est vrai car oui elle prête à la
réflexion alors ex-aequo il y avait
également celle d'un igloo canfin qui se
voulait voilà qu'on voit ici je crois
que c'est à elancourt alors celle-ci
qualité la force de l'image dans cpc là
c'est la pure décorations de noël s'ils
voulaient de ce qui a été fait en noir
et blanc
bon c'est une image c'est une image
intéressante aussi qui train nous
rappelle la fête si on peut je crois
qu'on reviendra sur ce point là quand ce
que je disais si voulez malheureusement
il ya personne sur cette image on a
l'impression
voilà donc en quatrième position il y
avait une avec un très beau feu
d'artifice
donc là on n'est plus vraiment sur le
thème de noël c'était plus c'est la fête
voilà tout donc c'est c'était vraiment
sur le plan artistique
si vous laisser aussi aussi le savez que
les feux d'artifice c'est pas facile à
photographier parce que le des images en
très vite c'est vrai si vous voulez les
pétards ça va très très vite
mais il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
quand même dans cette image c'est une
c'est une très belle image de
documentaires et que je crois mérite ce
sa place parce que bon on a peut-être
que dans la définition du concours n'a
peut-être pas été assez précis de bien
préciser que c'était les lumières de
fait alors en 2e position arrive et la
tour eiffel avec devant un jardin noël
alors celle-ci mais c'est pareil c'est
oublier aussi alors on voit la tête de
la tour eiffel qui est dans le
brouillard
il ya sur beaucoup de ses biens c'est
bien photographier puis on voit si vous
voulez dans le bas tout le village de
noël qu'ils et elles apparaissent donc
qui nous qui nous amène quand même vers
la fête vers la période dans laquelle
nous sommes à l'heure actuelle elle
prête c'est vrai plus à l'affairé alors
une qui était en jeu justement que vous
avez proposé une photo que vous allez
réaliser donc c'est une vitrine de noël
où on voit un petit enfant voilà devant
voilà c'était si vous voulez voilà les
l'image que je qualifie comme étant
vraiment la lumière de fait si vous
voulez les vitrines de noël illuminé et
le regard de cet enfant si blake est
ébloui par ce qu'il est en plein bois
est ce que je pourrais conseiller à nos
photographes amateurs qui nous regardent
si vous laisser que
malheureuse en fait heureusement nous
sommes sur une planète où il ya quand
même six milliards d individus et
souvent on voit que sur les photos
sylvia personnes on a l'impression que
notre planète est vide alors bon je
trouve que il est vrai qu'avec le droit
à l'image ce n'est pas facile mais c'est
toujours intéressant quand même de
montrer des hommes
il suffit de parfois bien souvent de
leur demander est ce que l'on peut vous
prendre en photo et là moi je dirais que
pour quand je pratique dans 95% des cas
des gens disent ok donc appel problème
si on est capable de l'expliquer notre
projet mais voilà la vérité voilà pour
humaniser la photographie et enfin à
leurs roulements de tambour le grand
gagnant du concours d'une donne la
grande gagnante exactement elle natacha
à favars voilà on découvre sa photo noël
chez pascal et alors là il n'ya pas
d'humains mais c'est en tout cas une
très belle un très beau cliché très
belles compositions voilà exactement
pourquoi est-ce que natacha savoir
remporte le concours
mais écoutez c'est le jury qui en a
décidé ainsi c'est pas ce n'est pas nous
si vous laissez et je trouve c'est une
belle composition c'est que c'est
vraiment les lumières de fait ce qu'on
peut on reprocher on regrettait un tout
petit peu je dire mais alors tout petit
peu et entre parenthèses c'est que
écoutez il ya personne sur cette image
souhaité tellement mieux si on a vu des
gens s'approcher de la table puisque
c'est lui mais c'est c'est la lumière de
fête avant de passer donc à table on
peut dire que natacha donc bah voilà
grâce appelle là à la société fuji ep
partenariat qu'il ya entre tv filet la
fédération tchèque de 50 euros donc à
utiliser ce la société fuji qui n'est
qu'une autre voisine puisque fuji est
installé à bois d'arcy donc ben écoutez
moi je dis bravo à un attacha et puis on
va peut-être parler du prochain concours
on dit également que donc on invite
natacha fava à nous rejoindre en plateau
justement pour la féliciter en direct et
donc oui vous le disiez prochain
concours donc le thème sera mais écoutez
on en a parlé on a ciblé c'est un
message d'espoir je pense que il faudra
que les ballons en ce début d'année si
vous laisser l'espoir en a terminé
l'année avec une certaine tristesse
et soyons optimistes pour 2016 donc un
joli sourire pour 2016 le vôtre des
jeunes sétois pourrait plaire donc la
date de présentation sera le 22 janvier
et on vous donne date limite des envois
le 17 juin
surtout ciblé lorsque les vous envoyer
des photos envoyées les dans le format
1920 pixels en hauteur de manière fiable
quand et pas de l'image trop lourde et
je suis à la même adresse rédaction à tv
fil 78 points comme et vous avez donc
jusqu'au 17 janvier pour envoyer vos
clichés envoyés les nombreux et on passe
tout de suite à notre rubrique
littérature merci c'est pourquoi et donc
comme ça que vendredi laurent gare un
gérant de la librairie du pavé du canal
de saint quentin en yvelines nous
propose sa sélection
cette fois ci il s'agit des routes du
miel d'eric tournerait et de sylla de
saint pierre on les écoute
alors bonjour aujourd'hui je vous
présente les routes du miel kate un beau
livre sur la fabrication et la récolte
de miel à travers la planète
donc c'est un livre qui est édité aux
éditions ausoni est donc en plus d'être
un beau livre avec deux fabuleuses
photos sur la récolte et les abeilles
sony nous apprend aussi énormément de
choses sur comment et récolté ce fameux
lecteur est tout tout au travers de la
planète qu'on apprend énormément de
choses sur comment et récolté à la main
en afrique
le miel comment il arrive à dompter tout
c'est toutes ces abeilles et
et donc l'auteur enfin les deux auteurs
égrène la planète complète pour voir un
peu comment on fait que ce soit au
milieu de la savane en afrique ce soit
dans les villes que ce soit à new york
ou à paris
vraiment il ya tout l'étalagé complet de
la récolte du miel dont ce livre écueils
du recensement de tous les apiculteurs
et de leurs méthodes de fonctionnement
moi j'ai surtout retenu un parmi tant
d'autres qui la récolte du miel au népal
on voit une personne donc un
interrupteur à flanc de falaise aller
chercher à la main suspendu avec des
cornes qui l'a forcément pressés
lui-même
voilà c'est vraiment là cette image moi
que je retiens de ce livre on voit
finalement que en plus de récolter
quelque chose de fabuleux pour eux il ya
aussi tous et cet art ancestral
finalement qu'ils arrivent à faire
perdurer sur la récolte de ce nectar est
à présent notre rubrique cinéma vous
n'aurez sans doute pas échappé à la
fièvre de la sortie mercredi 16 décembre
dernier du dernier star wars le réveil
de la force
alors on retrouve tout de suite vos
réactions au micro de gier imite quesada
scotch ou est-ce que tu chauffes eau des
points à 12h15 super ainsi par moments
c'est énorme et appuyé à 40 ans de
souvenirs et qui ont bon dos la
franchement c'était impressionnant
puis y ait beaucoup de à la fois du du
nouveau puits à la fois de ses
supérieurs je suis pas du tout déçu par
rapport par rapport au film c'était
vraiment vraiment très bien allez-y
alesi trop de clichés et de copier
coller peut-être des autres un peu comme
dans le même esprit qu'ils ont fait
jurassique world avec les anciens
jurassic park
ils ont réussi à trouver un scénario qui
nous tient en haleine et c'est vraiment
dans la suite du retour du jedi
on s'y retrouve complètement bien sûr
faut des repères comme pour se recaler
ça fait trente ans autour du jean et
mais un conseiller qui avait un peu de
répétitions fait par rapport aux ans à
starz pas il ya eu pas mal de clin
d'oeil mais en général mais il était
déjà un très bon rythme beaucoup
d'actions ont ce n'est pas pendant le
film puissant mon film cinéma toujours
cette semaine c'est bertrand pigné du
cinéma de saint cyr l'école les yeux
d'elsa qui nous donne son coup de coeur
de professionnels aujourd'hui en ce 16
décembre 2016 alors que la force se
réveille partout sur la france au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa notre coup de coeur ne
va pas être star wars le réveil de la
force parce que nous n'aurons qu'à
partir du 30 décembre pendant les
vacances mais c'est un autre film un
film que nous avons déjà passé une
semaine et que nous continuons à
soutenir le film s'appelle l'hermine
c'est un film de christian vincent
réalisateur assez reconnu dans le monde
du cinéma français qui met en scène
fabrice luchini et site se bat bay
tenues de scène qui est une actrice
norvégienne qu'on a pu voir dans la
série borgen le film s'appelle donc
l'hermine
évidemment il nous parle d'un d'un
tribunal d'un président de tribunal joué
par fabrice luchini et qu'ils
rencontrent à l'occasion d'un jury
d'assises
une femme pour laquelle il a eu un coup
de foudre et qui elle n'avait pas
répondu à son coup de foudre à ce moment
là le film va donc mêlés et cette
histoire d'amour manquer ce rendez vous
manqué cet acte manqué et puis un grand
film de tribunal à grand film qui va
nous raconter ce qu'est la réalité d'un
jury d'assises pour l'occasion d'une
affaire un peu grave puisqu'il s'agit
d'une mort d'enfants mais c'est un film
d'une très grande beauté il a été
présenté à la mostra de venise cette
année il a gagné le prix du scénario et
c'est très méritée parce que c'est
décrit d'une manière très très belle et
puis fabrice luchini a gagné le prix
d'interprétation masculin on aime ou on
aime pas fabrice luchini il en fait
parfois trop là il est d'une sobriété
absolument fantastique il est très très
bon
pas répondu à la cctv si pour moi 2 je
trouvais que j'en ai pour
plus de monde
je demande que d'harcourt
si vous très touchant très intelligents
et qui vous touchera forcément alors je
vous invite à le retrouver encore cette
semaine au cinéma les yeux d'elsa et
puis d'attendre encore trois semaines
pour retrouver celui là et avant de nous
quitter je vous propose quelques idées
sorties pour ce week end
ce soir vendredi 18 décembre à 20h30 au
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir je
vous propose la chanson de l'éléphant
une pièce de théâtre qui a obtenu deux
nominations aux molières 2014 et qui
réunit pierre cassignard et jean
baptiste maunier on en regarde un
extrait eagle cjga vous la personne
reste en dehors de tout ça elle est rusé
et vicieuse
mais vous comprenez pas tenu plus
intelligent beau stade ci il me faut une
preuve concrète que vous savez vraiment
quelque chose au sujet du dr lawrence
est quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir
avec les éléments premiers mois
peut-être à rien de stupide promet
prenez vous êtes une phrase rien de
stupide
ce soir toujours à 20 heures sur la
scène de la batterie à guyancourt pour
un concert pop électro qui réunira
bertrand belin lucioles et mines où on
découvre tout de suite un extrait du
dernier clip de lucioles
gfr 3 tu seras
je sens la nuit
bon
bien sûr
je ne suis pas violent
pourquoi changer
je donne je vais prier
et demain samedi 19 décembre à 18 heures
à la ferme de bel ébat de guyancourt
retrouver la forêt ébouriffés un
spectacle de danse jeune public pour
plonger dans un univers merveilleux
on va se quitter sur un air de fête avec
deux groupes yvelinois qui célèbrent
leur 20 ans cette année les joyeux
urbains qui propose une répétition
publique ce soir au scarabée à 19h et le
groupe vocal de jazz et majin qui
organise un concert demain samedi 19
décembre à 20h30 à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux fin de ce sept
huit week-ends je vous quitte en musique
sur un extrait des joyeuses urbain très
bon week-end à tous
mais monsieur mais c'est
mais qu'elle sait
trop sympa fait péter le sucre et la
staff et moi fais moi un bon café
dans la publicité
la police et les jeunes membres tous et
le dialogue tué à très bientôt les gens
fervent du café